you're watching swipe on the show this
week no longer just to gain virtual
reality hits Hollywood meet the lifelike
robots turning heads in Tokyo here we
glow why cycling it nice could be about
to get safer and we go beyond there in
this week games review hello and welcome
to swipe from here the BFI IMAX in
London where this week we're finding out
how virtual reality could transform the
movie business
here's Angela the initial focus of
oculus rift may have been on virtual
reality gaming but it seems they're now
making room for it in Hollywood the
Banshee chapter is a horror film out
just in time for an immersive Halloween
scare and it's also the first
feature-length flick to use oculus
hardware produced by Star Trek actor
Zachary Quinto its makers have teamed up
with virtual reality experts to give the
film a VR overhaul creating software
that gives the viewer the sensation of
being inside the film it's an exciting
time I think we're at the stage where
we're gonna try this out maybe on not so
well-known films at the moment that have
so much height just to see how audiences
take to it and I think it's a clever
strategy whether or not it's seen as
maybe a gimmick to start off with is
probably a surface reaction but I'm
pretty sure that Studios directors those
who want to embrace new technology have
more of a long-term strategy being
played out unlike the regular oculus
rift experience the VR version of the
banshee chapter is limited to a 120
degree field of view rather than a full
360 degree shot this means you'll be
able to look around the scene but you
won't be able to see behind the camera
and studios have also been experimenting
with offering shorter virtual
experiences to help market new releases
the oculus rift headgear was recently
made available to people in cinemas to
help promote Christopher Nolan's new
sci-fi epic interstellar but what was
the added hardware costs needed for a
headset per person viewing can we expect
virtual reality films to become more
mainstream in the near future
I think oculus rift headsets in cinemas
isn't something we're gonna see soon in
a way that 3d glasses are given out as
you go in them I can't see that
happening for quite some years I mean
the oculus rift kit itself is still
developmental but a kid
it's not actually commercially available
maybe cinemas will adopt it maybe that's
a way of transmitting new types of film
so if you're hoping for a dose of
virtual reality along with your popcorn
and pick a mix you'll have to wait the
personal headsets are yet to hit the
shelves and filmmakers are still
dabbling with the idea of including it
in the final cut Angela Bond Sky News
well oculus rift isn't just being used
to transform the way movies are being
made
it's also being used to help market them
to now as part of promotions for the new
sci-fi interstellar movie here at the
BFI IMAX they've been letting people
have a go but what it's like to be
onboard the endurance spacecraft which
is featured in the movie and now I'm
about to have a go to
Oh
we must reach far beyond our own
lifespans all the roofs the roof closing
in on me
oh wow I can see everything behind me
Islam this is brilliant Wow I'm going
through it's not anything to our galaxy
here we go up through the windows on
board the endurance spacecraft prepare
for zero oh oh
prepare for zero gravity get up yeah
save the world okay so now I feel like
I'm flying
oh wow wow I'm going right up to a
planet NOW whoa
actually we want to get there in one
piece hang on
well we got this far rather than any
human in history well not far enough
that's it
that was so much fun if that's the
future of cinema it's gonna be fantastic
and I'm really looking forward to it was
far more real than I ever imagined
virtual reality could be I recommend it
you're watching swype later on we've
heard of driverless cars what about
flying ones laughs and the rest of the
week's best tech news but first everyone
loves robots or we're better to go and
see them than the robot capital of the
world Japan
Chloe's been taking a look at some of
the wonderful creations at Tokyo
designers week you guys look cool she
says this may look like a person but is
in fact a robot called Asuna she's a
humanoid Android capable of intricate
facial expressions the company behind
her say they're calling her an
everlasting girl she moves like a human
and the texture is very like real skin
she looks like a real one first I
thought she was human but I soon figured
out she wasn't more than 13-hundred
designers architects musicians and
artists took part in the Tokyo design
Expo but it was the robot that stole the
limelight especially the musical ones
this choir of robot singers called the
Siemens perform their very own
mechanical harmony using artificial
lungs
others played guitar chords
and some clapped on demand but not
everyone understood the point of them I
don't get the artistic concept I guess
two people who made them have a talent
that I don't possess the exhibition has
been going for nearly 30 years
it started in small tents of affiliated
shops but this year has been given a new
name to reflect its growth from
architecture to entertainment a great
number of artists are participating in
this event so we had to call it a genius
Expo rather than a design art or music
Expo in order to embrace their diversity
the 10-day event which ends next Monday
has also been held in overseas
exhibitions in Milan and London
organizers are hoping to expand it to
New York next year Chloe Culp and Sky
News you're watching swipe up next with
chasing criminals well Cameron Robinson
is in our games review but first here's
our roundup of anything you might have
missed over the past few days last week
on Spike we told you about the
hoverboard well now we have a flying car
the error mobile three as a high tech
cockpit and wings that fold up behind
the cabin the cars creators have been
working on the idea for more than 25
years but this is the most advanced
prototype
you can't buy one yet though it's still
being tested UK roads could soon be
covered in glow-in-the-dark cycle lanes
if tests on Dutch roads are successful
route 66 of the future uses a special
green paint that charges in daylight the
first test is in December the artist
behind the project thinks it'll make
roads safer and says authorities in
Birmingham and London are interested
Nintendo has made a surprise return to
profit following four years of losses
are struggling Japanese games firm made
an operating profit of 1.2 million
pounds between July and September this
time last year they lost 18 billion yen
the company says it's down to a weaker
yen and strong demand for new games the
Met Office is getting an upgrade in the
shape of a 140 ton supercomputer the 97
million pound machine will perform more
than 16-thousand trillion calculations
per second
it should make forecast more accurate
even predicting the weather for areas as
small as 300 meters the Kray XC 40
weighs the same as 11 double-decker
buses and now it's time for our games
review and the range of new releases
right now is huge which is why we got
Cameron Robinson's pick a few of his
favorites the biggest game to come out
the last few weeks has to be
civilization beyond Earth if you played
a civilization game before you'll be
right at home with this one because it's
the same formula and it's got that same
wonderful just one more turn kind of
aesthetic to it you just wanna keep
playing but what's new insulation beyond
Earth as a name suggests is that you are
no longer on earth you're taken to the
stars
carried aloft to the horse and reached
is our backstory about how the world's
on gone horribly wrong and everyone's
had to leave so when you colonize this
new planet you're not just facing off
against other colonists from Earth it is
alien life to deal with and they're far
more challenging and the barbarians of
past civilization games but yet if so
there's a lot of new stuff in there but
at the same time if you're fan of the
series we sit down with civilization
beyond Earth you'll know exactly what
you do but the legend of korra is a
really fantastic animated series on
Nickelodeon and a game has come out now
to tie in with with the animation and
unfortunately it's not particularly
great now I really wanted to enjoy this
game because I love the animated series
it's a it's really charming and witty
and the storylines are fantastic but
none of that transitions to this game
it's kind of like what we used to get
when we used to get these movie and
series tie-in games that were kind of
like an afterthought and feel a bit
thrown together and it very much is like
that there's some fun to be had in the
combat but it's pretty bland pretty
disappointing and it's a difficult one
to really recommend unless you are just
an insanely huge fan of the game and
just want to play it regardless
lords of the falling is a brand-new
third-person action combat heavy can a
fantasy game it's very similar to the
Dark Souls series which some people
might have heard of before but it says
it's unlike the new generation of
consoles and it looks gorgeous
they obviously looked at Dark Souls and
tried to copy this idea and it's all
about being really difficult combat
except this game is actually quite a lot
easier so if you've been put off by the
difficulty of these kind of games in the
past this could be one for you you play
as a super grumpy hero who almost looks
like he can't be bothered to be on the
adventure which is quite amazing but the
adventure itself is actually a lot of
fun from the players point of view it's
all about combat it's all about
collecting loot and it's a great game to
check out if you're into this can a
third-person combat heavy fantasy epic
so the detail is again it's come out
this week on Steam so that's on the PC
and Mac and also a Linux if you've got a
Linux machine as well and this is really
interesting it's like a film the war
esque point-and-click crime thriller and
while the story is a bit hackneyed like
you know you play a grizzled cop who
will do anything to get results and you
spend you you know I spent the very
beginning of the scene like smashing
some guy's head on the table to get
answers out of him which of course is
it's wildly inappropriate for a
policeman to do but it's that kind of
story so if you like games like The
Walking Dead's it's very very similar
it's obviously riding that wave of
popularity I would say the art is not
quite as good as what you might have
seen with those games there's a lot to
be had here so if you like the sound of
a crime point-and-click you should
definitely check it out
well that's it for this week but don't
forget you can stay up to date with all
the latest tech stories on sky news for
iPad smartphone apps on Sky News com see
you again next time bye-bye
you